stranger things fans suspected from the
start that l's number 11 tattoo meant
she was just one of several test
subjects experimented upon at hawkins
lab
and season two confirmed that with the
appearance of carly aka number eight
yupikai movie lovers it's jan here and
today i want to delve deep into some
hidden clues you may have missed in
season 2 which reveals secrets about
more young people likely abducted by
hawkins lab for experimentation
and who may appear in season 3 and
beyond obviously i'll be discussing
spoilers from both
seasons so take care if you're not up to
date
carly and elle's tattoo suggests that
there are at least nine other test
subjects in project mk
ultra and given that the lost sisters
who spent time together in the lab's
rainbow room
have different powers to each other with
carly being able to cast illusions
we can assume the other young people
subjected to the lab's experiments may
also have developed
different abilities although carly
herself doesn't mention any other
hawkins test subjects
eleven learned about her lost sister
when she read her mother's mind
and investigated further with the files
her aunt becky gave her
and it's in those files that we get some
glimpses of news reports about
abductions and missing children and
mothers
carly's file was among those papers so
it's very likely that eleven's mother
thought those reports were connected to
project mk
ultra and the hawkins lab the first
file that 11 flips past is a news
clipping about a cleveland girl who's
gone missing in indiana
the report states that a 16 year old
junior high school honours student and
girls basketball team captain from ohio
went missing at some point after leaving
an indiana junior high gym
to go back to her bus that was returning
home there's no date on this clipping
but it's eerie that this potentially has
a connection to the ending of season 2
where we see the shadow monster in the
upside down looming over the hawkins
middle school gym
the news report also states that the
girl's father is a widower so she has a
missing mother
and her father describes her as a genius
and exceptionally strong for her age
this could mean her mother was
experimented on at hawkins or elsewhere
and after leaving the mk ultra project
gave birth to a girl with special gifts
the mother could have later died from
the effects of the experiments but the
hawkins lab learned about the gifted
girl and abducted her while she was
visiting indiana
there's also another intriguing
possibility though which is that the
girl was actually playing basketball at
hawkins middle school itself
where we know there's a portal that both
the demogorgon and 11 use to cross
between the upside down and the real
world
well if this girl was gifted like 11 she
might have stumbled across the portal
and traveled to the upside down either
willingly or accidentally
where perhaps she got lost or maybe she
even created that portal in hawkins
middle school in the first place
okay so if that's not crazy enough yet
there's more in the clipping the news
report continues mentioning that a girl
matching the missing girl's general
description was later discovered
wandering around
an indiana suburb there are various
possibilities here
one is that this girl was abducted by
the hawkins lab but she escaped and they
managed to find her and take her back to
the facility before she got to safety
another possibility is that the hawkins
lab guys arranged for a similar looking
girl to be seen in the neighborhood as a
way of trying to hide the fact that the
real girl had gone missing
or they could simply have had carly use
her powers to cast an illusion
making it look like the girl was still
out there remember they've done these
kind of things before
for example releasing a fake dead body
for will to cover up the fact that he'd
gone missing in the upside down
alternatively another pretty far-fetched
possibility which may have sped through
your mind if you're a fan of the flash
tv show
is that the upside down is a replica of
our world just that it's been corrupted
by the shadow monster
after all we see the same buildings from
hawkins in the upside down so could
there have been doppelganger versions of
people somewhere in the alternate
dimension
and a doppelganger of the missing girl
was sent to our world from the upside
down
okay back to the other reports behind
the cleveland clipping is another one
that only has some very sparse details
the title appears to read another girl
lost and you can see the words go police
mentioned in the tiny bit of the report
which is showing
perhaps suggesting that the chicago
police were mentioned if that's the case
then this looks like a chicago girl
who's disappeared too
another file which 11 flicks past
mentions a baby boy abducted from a
memphis hospital
the circumstances reported around the
abduction are particularly suspect as
the account states that the boy went
missing with a nurse who turned up for
work unexpectedly after being off sick
for a week
the article then states that the nurse
was discovered dead from a gunshot wound
at her house but the boy was missing
it sounds like the nurse was probably
used by the hawkins lab or the mk ultra
project
to abduct the boy and then she was
killed to avoid her squealing
the fact she was off sick and then
suddenly appeared at work may suggest
she spent time either willingly or under
coercion at the hawkins lab or another
secret government facility
it seems like the mk ultra project were
looking for the child's mother because
she was probably an ex-test subject and
they needed the nurse to find out when
or where she was going to give birth
the fact that the show has gone to the
effort of putting so much information
and a photo in this clipping
makes me think this is another gifted
character which the show runners could
be setting up to appear in a future
season
there's also something intriguing in
another newspaper clipping just behind
the baby boy article
if you look carefully there's some text
about someone missing from san diego
san diego is of course in california and
we know that two new main characters max
and billy moved from california to
hawkins in season two
though we don't know where from exactly
we do know that billy has a lot of
issues though some of which may be
explained by his authoritarian bullying
father but we don't know anything about
billy's mother and why his father is no
longer with her in some ways the
introduction of billy in season two was
a bit sketchy and perplexing as he was a
real jerk
pretty much the whole time so i do
wonder whether the showrunners decided
to include him more for potential future
storylines
and in fact the duffer brothers have
said that they wanted to have a human
villain in the show that could disrupt
the lives of their characters
so it's a long shot but i wonder if
there's any potential connection between
billy's mother
and this possible missing child or
person in san diego
there's also one more set of clippings
which are a bit more cryptic
one says a mother and daughter from
pawtucket have gone missing
there's also a picture of a young boy
which mentions a county hospital
and another article seems to talk about
a wave of disappearances of children and
teens
at the bottom of the piece there's
mention of the gary police department
and gary is a small city in indiana not
far from chicago
now i don't expect we'll see all of
these reported abductions or missing
children in future seasons some of the
children or adults may be dead
long gone or not important for the
overall storyline the duffer brothers
want to tell in the show
some may also just be random reports
that are unconnected to the hawkins lab
however i do think that the missing baby
boy and the missing girls basketball
captain are very specific and detailed
reports as i think we'll see feed into
either season three or four
by the way if you cast your mind back to
season one you'll remember that when
hopper was reading newspaper articles
about dr brenner one of them mentions
six subjects coming forward to give
testimony about the project mk ultra
experiments
and alongside that there was a picture
of young women dressed in the kind of
hospital gown we see elwha when she
first escapes in the lab
so just as terry ives who took part in
the mk ultra project gave birth to a
gifted daughter in the form of 11
any of those women in that photograph
could also be the mothers of similarly
gifted children who will appear in the
show going forward
on top of that given carly's awesome
power to make people see whatever she
wants them to
there's a possibility that hopper's
flashbacks to his last days with his
daughter
are merely memories of illusions the
hawkins lab made him
see and that really his daughter sarah
was also one of the children abducted
and experimented on
something else i think is interesting is
the strong x-men vibe to the show which
has been clear since the very first
episode eleven already has powers
reminiscent of various x-men like
professor x magneto and jean grey
and i wonder whether the duffer brothers
are considering potentially teaming
l up with multiple gifted individuals
like carly and others out there who have
yet to meet
i love how the seasons have developed so
far but if the shadow monster is going
to be an ongoing big bad
at some point i imagine it will take
more than just what 11 can currently do
to defeat it
it's possible that 11 could continue to
power up as she has done this season but
it wouldn't surprise me if eventually
the monster's defeat
ended up being a group effort so what do
you think about having more gifted
children or individuals showing up in
future seasons of stranger things
and do you have any theories or
predictions on who they'll be
and what powers they'll have let me know
what you think in the comments below and
don't forget to also subscribe to my
channel for a chance to win an awesome
stranger things funko pop
i'm currently working on more stranger
things plus thor ragnarok videos
so hit the notification bell to get my
new videos as soon as they're live
and in the meantime you can check out
more videos you might like here
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers
you